all right welcome everyone there is a
three minute stream delay so I'll be
talking basically to everyone it's in
three minutes from now this is a choker
Cup
it's a Invitational choker tournament
the first of its kind you can use the
command exclamation point choker in the
chat for more information
actually exclamation choker and
exhibition choker Cup and that should
provide all the information people need
this is new I'm a little bit nervous I
don't know not sure what to expect
yes
taki with bits thanks foggy I turned off
the sound so bits won't make silence but
they'll still appear in the event list
Neal is back to welcome Neal so good to
see some VIPs some mods I mean make sure
oh we can start playing okay let me just
end a challenge okay it's starting okay
so I'm playing as white and I'm applying
to my rook good card ooh - ruffs
so I figured get a third rook it gets
demoted to a pawn and the small blind oh
let's do a min raise time in race let's
race I wanted to play aggressively
we'll see where he's at
these these rounds can go very fast
Lisa clashes okay so he folds maybe that
came across that's too strong but and
it's nice to get kind of a early footing
so now I'm playing this black I'll be
the small blind now blinds increase oh
yeah wait I'm new
okay so I got two queens which is
actually better than average starting
hand
I'll see what he's up to I'm sure things
are running smoothly he breezes he
raises 5k oh let's call I'll probably
just get it all in mmm yeah well this is
probably gonna determine things let's
shove all in okay so this could very
much determine the outcome which is not
bad like if we're gonna go all in so
early I I'm happy to have a queen
there's no way he's gonna fall yeah okay
but he took a lot of time there okay so
overall what's the value of this this is
18 points so this is better than average
these whites I have to be careful of
tricky tricks of opening preparation
basically here's a pawn that's good
that's a weird placement for a pawn I
think I want the pawn chain from Esau
and e65
and time starts ticking what time will
be very relevant has another pond oh so
he prevents that's the funny
that's a funny setup so he's preventing
kind of Plan C 5 so let's play pawn I
guess it f7 just try and have a one
stable pawn island he has two pylons
which in some sense it could be a
strength he has an outside past be pawn
on the other hand it could be a weakness
a nine-game so it's double-edged as a
bishop ok so there's a question where to
put my Knights I think one night belongs
here preventing any Bishop Bishop c6
ideas and yeah so he's gonna try and
attack me so worst-case scenario he has
a queen which I kind of have to plan for
a place and I'm at f8 making sure there
is there's no work h8 check immediately
if he has a queen I'm lost but I'll try
and fight gives are up that's good so
I'll place the Queen on g7 and then he's
he's pretty much toast here what's
material Queen it's basically Queen and
night for two rooks but I'm threatening
the bishop and the pollen on on c3 now
castling and castling is legal both ways
for white I know if he knows that me
make sure things are going ok okay
things are better okay
I think things were unstable from his
owned but okay this position is very
unstable at least in terms of the chess
and if I win this hands and then I'll
win the clash cuz I was a high on ships
and he's taking his time he's not
resigning but okay let's take a pawn
please rookie wine hmm still take some
technique bishop is a bit annoying to do
right here so it's important to note the
Queen controls h8 so he doesn't have
work h8 which actually took me longer
than usual to tie TANF I but yeah that
is nice very important out boardvision
in these these open positions and yeah I
think I want to put the night here just
blockade the pawn and then probably when
I got a chance play e6 even e5 like e5
96 and then basically just develop u5
does block the Queen to control h8 but
that should be ok let's throw in a check
now probably five maybe I don't know II
635 no I'm nervous
the e5 so if look so Roxy one I thought
was some small issue but then Queen g5
Forks the rook and Bishop ok so very
similarly this works did I have that the
move I may have had that the move before
queen g6 I think I was maybe scared of
rock h8 but ok now I'm winning at least
the record Bishop Bishop c6 doesn't help
because I take and the rock is still
attached
okay so he's gonna try and fight let's
take a free bishop no he does that so I
can check and then I can play Knight c4
and it's a triple fork it's got some
fork my emotes this is so nice yeah so
your resigns that was very nice
opponent yeah and he didn't have enough
to keep playing so I win I win the clash
so let's update that now I think we were
supposed to take a break after the first
clash you see take a break after first
clash right and now let me update the
score I'm gonna exit and then I'll
probably just resend the challenge okay
that was a very good start
let me update the score score okay
that's a very good start I didn't want
to get off on a bad foot so its first
two three so anything can happen
maybe he's he's bit more alert now so
they say wait one minute
yeah um I've kind of lost track of time
I'll give it like a maybe another 30
seconds let's go and get ready to
challenge the ginger GM he's currently
in a match oh I think you have to exit
match for me to challenge again okay
also a whole lot more people thanks
everyone for tuning in
yeah just use the choker command or the
choker Cup command there should be mods
to answer questions there's always
telling you to answer questions
thanks again talky for the bits yeah I
really can't complain with that first
round I mean I think in general if you
have a queen you should just try and get
everything in so so okay let me
challenge again one minute should have
passed no challenge sent
[Music]
now after that I don't know how it's
gonna affect him he might be playing
more safe so I might want to that might
be a opportunity to play a bit more
aggressively but we'll see all right so
I'm playing as White's as a bishop and a
ruck okay this is another very good
starting hand equivalent to having like
Queen maybe not quite but let's yeah
let's raise listening raise this is
definitely time to play aggressively and
so far I haven't revealed much in terms
of my betting because I've I've been
betting pretty aggressively he goes
all-in okay so I'm I'm I'm ready to call
worst-case Smit he probably has a queen
but if he has a queen it should still be
a fight these capons not great Queen is
very good rook is okay this is amazing
hand I'll be surprised if he has
something even close to the strength
let's place a pawn actually don't know
where maybe pawn to d3 so I only have
one one Bishop so I want to keep the
option of placing my bishop on a long
diagonal
if you reconceive rook on c1 looks kind
of nice because I'm threatening rooks
here I'm trying to induce him to place
like a major piece on a tour BA and then
I can start attacking from from the
diagonal like a bishop can go on G 2 or
H 2 if he if he has like a rook probably
it's best to place on d8 he might play
some minor piece on d8 but there's no
way and there's no way that this is
going to be a fight I mean I think he
just chose me he was tilted from the
last round he chose a an unfortunate
time to go all in
but to be fair I got really good cards
with the Queen and rook draw so he's
taking his time
actually one mistake I made when I first
started playing this game is taking too
much time in the placement face so he
places a rook so unless yeah he might
have a pawn that that might be a tricky
tricky idea I might as well face a
bishop trying to imagine what he might
have
yeah let's place a bishop here
I probably shouldn't take too much time
because but I should be should be
prepared for the worst-case scenario so
he does have a pawn that was very smart
but I'll take sorrow he's gonna defend
[Music]
worse case scenario he has like two
queens I guess if he was dealt five
pawns in a row but he wouldn't go all-in
if he was dealt two pawns initially so
he probably has some kind of minor piece
he might have a queen
um so I like kind of like the Queen on
g2 I could consider placing it on b2 but
in g2 has a lot of merits it was very
smart of him to to keep the pawn to
place but if he has a queen I guess I'm
up almost spilled my drink there if he
has a queen I still have a bishop for a
pawn if he has a minor piece and I'm
just completely winning it's completely
winning regardless of what the ads
pretty much let's imagine he does have a
queen maybe on a 7 is the best place
gives a knight okay that's beautiful
so I can probably just calculate some
kind of forcing maybe it's not
completely forcing but maybe it is
pretty forcing yeah just queen g6 and
then if King f8 is really the only move
and then Bishop f4 if King G it then
Queen g8 would win I know a Bishop f4
threatening me than one only way to stop
it is to move the e pawn and now there
should be CH six hmm trying to find the
clear-cut win I could just play a
waiting move want to spend too much time
here
yeah I'll throw in I'll throw in this
like I want to have him get initiative
by training now this and then Roxy
Saturn and he's just toast so I could
check check
let's just do this keep it simple so the
only thing I'm concerned about is a
mouse slip or steal any tricks there is
pre moving now but I'm not going to fool
around with it too much
I wanna play Bishop e7
I could send him little emoji things but
I don't want to rub it in too much and
your time is very relevant as well let's
take a pause so he's probably hoping for
a song like weird stalemate which is not
gonna happen ever
so I fish it yeah I'm just trying to
like meet the king let's play this if
King a six queen bee sixes means he has
a pollen - but this is this is more
forcing the King has to move to a dark
square I checked with the bishop and
then it's meats first meats or he ran
out of time okay
so I didn't get the choke me but okay I
want another game another clash I should
say was that the first I think that was
the first game of that clash - so I
can't imagine how tilted he is but okay
I shouldn't feel bad so let's exit yeah
from his spots
you really have to choose when you go
all in now I'm yeah I'm curious if he's
gonna be more tilted and he'll go all in
or if he'll just try and be a bit more
safe but again I think my strategy I
just want to go all in when I have well
I have cards that I can fight with or
pieces I can fight with I should say so
I'll give it a minute and get ready to
challenge him beyond curious actually
what he was dealt the first two cards of
that last one because he didn't have a
queen it's possible he could have had
like two rooks or rooking Minor and just
didn't have a better follow-up than what
I had
so yeah that worked out nicely yeah
shout out to everyone in the chat yet
again there is a three-minute delay so
if you have questions hopefully other
people can can respond we make sure
we're on the same page here I think
that's been about a minute I'll send a
challenge and Simon can choose when he
wants to to begin well let me update the
score actually up to its core so to two
to zero so there won't be any adoptions
here but I'll try and stay clean
hopefully this will be our last clash
let's challenge let me text Simon
challenge cents okay I think there's
been some luck on my side maybe in some
respects but it'll be interesting to
kind of analyze it's like to go back
watch both streams and see maybe what he
could have done better so I'm playing
black I think it's just random playing
black and I am okay rook and pawn this
is kind of an average hand I think I'll
check I could be aggressive to rook and
pawn as well let's check let's some
let's see what I get okay so this is
this is decent so if I get another pawn
or get another rook then there will be
some promotion to a queen minor would be
would be the worst possibility oh it's
that it's bad another spots or another
diamond race
and see what he wants to do if he shoves
I don't know what I'll do
he raises I think I should just put them
all in this might be a bad play but if I
got a queen I'll be in good shape
I think it's statistically the odds are
actually okay I get a queen so pawn
would have promoted to a queen as well
another good hand like all the hands
I've gone all in I've had a queen I've
had good cards and this is this is
valued at twenty one the average Shoukry
hand I think is like may be valued at
fifteen or sixteen so now it's just a
question where to put the pawns and
white moves first so I do have to be
careful with placing here the pawn
that's a good sign I think I want to for
my pawn chain
I also want to keep a time advantage
it's funny when he does this this planet
before I'm slightly surprised he has not
for the pawn at she where should this go
who's gonna say I'm slightly surprised
he hasn't put a pawn on h-file because I
know how much he loves Harry what does
what does be Barry or been maybe bang
Danny okay so he has a bishop so I
should be having a better hand let's
hide the fact that I have a promoted
pawn rook I don't know what this I know
it's yellow so I might confuse some
people but it's just it's a card that
was previously a pawn but because I got
three pawns it was promoted to a rook so
even if he has a rook he can place on c1
like I can just defend by placing
something like Queen on g7 or Eric on b8
worst-case scenario he has Queen and
rook and even in that case I'm in better
places rook on each - so let's put a
rock on g8 I don't think he'll be able
to attack me on the obvious way
now the rook is tied down to the bishop
on g2 so he could play some like if he
has a queen or he could place it on c1
trying to be sneaky but then I'll place
my Queen somewhere maybe b8 or d7 if he
has a minor piece I mean he's just dead
I think regardless even if he has a
queen Wow he does have a queen so it's
gonna be a small fight I probably want
to place a queen on c7
[Music]
De Quincey seven takes takes there's
already some calculation to do leather
option is placing Queen on D seven or be
eight or even no I can't place on a six
to seven takes takes I think I do want
to simplify okay I spend a lot of time
there but I'm still up on time up the
exchange
well I can't pre move it was letting me
pre move yesterday but maybe and maybe
they changed it or something coming a
for forgot about that move but I have
King f8 should keep me safe so the tide
is between c1 which is very hard to stop
he has King f2 King f2 Queen b6 so
there's no drawing arrows he f2 Queen b6
yeah okay so now I can calculate he's
gonna try and plant the bishop on c6
[Music]
let's start by giving a check I can't
think why not for those Queen controls
f4 again boardvision let's play this
move
now now this looks nice
trying to keep the time advantage
threatening Queen g3 the rook is tied
down to the bishop Queen f4 is also a
threat I think Queen g3 is pretty
unstoppable
if Kim Ji Won rook c1 just wins
and I really have to thank the the gods
who who tell me the cards
um Queen a for therefore just wins right
the card gods or the Cheska's or the
choker gods and this is me right about
to be choked mate
Quincy one is only legal move cuz yeah
the bishops King don't resign give me a
choke mates come on I want the choke
mates or the flag a clean flag okay I
think that's the match that was maybe
slightly easier than expected
I think I I I just got really good cards
maybe he should have he should have been
a bit more cautious in the betting face
but yeah that was quick
Simon Says well done very very courteous
it's gonna say thanks
the choker gods were kind to me okay
so now now what to do there is a
three-minute delay I can see my stream
people are still watching the final game
I think well I'm supposed to do is end
the stream and Kyrie is chest 24 on
Twitch that's 24 YouTube was though was
doing official broad official commentary
[Music]
okay so they're on YouTube I can trade a
youtube channel
so maybe what I'll do is I think I do
have to end the stream they might even
end it for me we're using some different
software I'll be joining the call and I
mean just pull up I'll share the link to
the test one before YouTube go here we
go so the link is in the chat it was in
the chat like three minutes ago because
yeah time is weird when there's a delay